[Music]
Gotham reunion gonna say right now
definitely the best episode since the
show has come back since the hiatus this
oh this is good this this is what I love
about Gotham insanity on top of build up
on top of a couple of new twists on top
of making me so excited to see what
happens next
there be spoilers from here on out that
be your warning so oh man so I still
wish they hadn't recasts IV however I've
been able to I don't want to say get
over that cuz I still think it was a
dumb idea but I've been able to get on
board with this IV for this episode
because yeah she's working I wish there
was more of a connection to the IV that
we had prior to this but she's
definitely working here a heck of a lot
better than when she was first
introduced and she was just doing the
you know seduce II like having her
having her go Gotham size than just
trying to get she the third or the
fourth person who's tried to poison
and/or kill the entire city III got a
guy I gotta go back and do a count on
that but yeah she's just working better
here cuz she's more nuts here I think I
think that's what helps whenever Gotham
tries to do even slightly restrained it
ends up not working as well when it goes
for broke that's when it works this
episode this episode goes for broke so
you've got Ivy trying to enact this
scheme this plan this mass murder thing
so there's there's your baseline and
your big thing that you're trying to
stop but you've also got Bruce coming
off the heels of almost having died and
trying to you know pick up the pieces
again reaching out to Alfred and I love
Alford's first answer name is just this
growly no I'd love that and then this
was great and like the episode didn't
even draw attention of this but Alfred
says you know you can't tell me you've
changed you have to show me and instead
of immediately figuring out how to do
that what does Bruce do he goes to
Selene instead to see if she'll help him
because he's always had that safety net
he's always had people around him
willing to I don't want to say do the
work for him but willing to help him
through whatever he's going through now
that's not to undercut his painter is
damaged he's had plenty but he's always
had help so I do I love that his first
instinct when being rejected by someone
who's always helped them before is to
immediately go to somebody else who
usually helps them as opposed to do the
thing that's harder which is to actually
step up and prove to Alfred that he is
changing but then when he does make that
move to protect Alfred and to try and
help other people and when the lights
got cut in that room and it was just it
wasn't it wasn't quite hans zimmer
batman you know blue but it was
reminiscent of that and so that I was
like oh I'm really enjoying that like
they're walking Bruce right now right up
to the line of becoming Batman I'm
really enjoying that and I I know a lot
of people who watch Gotham and our fans
of Gotham are really big on Bullock I've
never disliked Bullock I've enjoyed him
I've never been in love with him him I
did with Jim you know admitting to him
exactly what's going and saying I need
your help
that felt like a yes that got me more
excited for Bullock's involvement than I
have been in quite a while
again not disparaging the character I
like him but he doesn't make my top five
favorite characters he actually might
not even make the top ten he's still
good but that was a good moment in when
it was built up to well within
internally within the episode and he has
couple of break mo I love Jim Jim gets
his moment to escape Harvey who's under
IV spell by saying wait do you think her
hair's more scarlet or Auburn and
Harvey's just like you know that's a
good question just taking his eye off
the ball for a second Jim bolts we've
got the the Riddler now effectively back
which was something I was iffy on I've
kind of been up and down on Ed's whole
thing this season I was finding it
interesting as he was finding a new
place you know in the world having he
thought lost his intellect and and try
trying to be kind of a decent guy but
Jim but kind of being a jerk about it
because sort of who he is I was finding
that interesting but it did seem like an
odd place to take the character bringing
him back to just full-on being the
Riddler again in some ways feels like
like a I don't want to say a step back
because it's not like it's a downgrade
the Riddler's a lot of fun but in some
ways it does feel like I didn't we kind
of do this already but at the same time
they've got him paired with Oz well
right off the bat and that was the extra
thing that sold it I was enjoying the
The Riddler
you know persona and his head thing cuz
I like that kind of thing in general but
if it had just been him coming back like
just him looking at them earlier I'm in
control again I would have been like
yeah okay but the fact that it's Oswald
there with him and then we get the two
of them face to face I'm like yes yes
yes yes yes that was what brought it up
that extra notch that's what sold it to
me something that otherwise I would have
been like I don't know this is really
the way to go Sofia been probably one of
her best moments bro
and then the hand smash on Lee that was
that was rough that I so you know props
to Gotham for that one and I think Lee
was due for another reminder that you
know she's clever and she's figuring out
how to play
but she's still trying to play against
pros so I will be really curious to see
what the next step for her is like I
kind of want to see her go nuclear on
again Sofia I'm not sure it'll go there
cuz I think the show is really trying to
preserve her integrity her moral
integrity but yeah I kind of I kinda
just want to see her wreck shop now
coming out of this we'll see but I you
know it was it was a good intense moment
I'll be curious to see where where
things go from here
and and Selena facing down ivy again
there were characters and moments that
I've been iffy on up to this one but
it's something about the way that they
sold it in specific moments in this
episode something about Selena facing
down this version of Ivy made me
appreciate this version of Ivy more I
think it's the way Selena dealt with her
spoke to her and interacted with her got
me hooked didn't better the same with
the returning of the Riddler having
Oswald there you know with that maniacal
grin on his face was the extra bit to
make this thing this plot move that I'm
otherwise if you've out somehow work in
the moment this was just a heck of a lot
of stupid crazy fun and yes I know
Gotham is stupid
it's stupid in the way a soap opera is
but oh my god I love this show this way
I'll be nervous coming back next week
because when I have this much fun with
an episode it can frequently be a
letdown with with whatever comes next
but right now yeah Gotham reunion did
you see it what were your thoughts on
whatever they are drop somebody got only
comments and let's talk about it there's
all the stuff to do like like or
subscribe or support me on patreon a bio
t-shirt and follow me on Twitter etc etc
etc links for all that stuff that I
mentioned plus a bunch more because I do
way too many things links down in the
description so until next
I'm this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]